this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode jonathan is checking out
the wasteland weaponry of fallout 4.
this this particular site with two
screws coming in from either side to
form like a crude reticle really makes
zero sense there's no point having a
scope tube if there's no glass in it
it's not magnifying it's not achieving
anything if you want to see more of
jonathan's thoughts on the firearms of
fallout make sure to check out our
videos on both fallout 3 and fallout new
vegas and be sure to subscribe for more
videos just like this one if there are
any other games guns and mechanics that
you guys want to see jonathan breakdown
let us know in the comment section below
and if you'd like to help out the royal
army's museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to
jonathan i find the 10 millimeter pistol
in the fallout games a bit of a quirky
thing i quite like the design it's a
little bit reminiscent of the blade
runner blaster which of course has its
own place in in the franchise in a way
it's got some extraneous greeblies on it
there are two parallel levers either
side that as the slide comes to the rear
um those levers drop so they're
operating something or they are being
operated by the slide and presumably
they are doing something inside i could
not tell you what that is they seem to
be just there for visual interest
movement detected curious
the laser musket is it a musket i
suppose it's a musket in the sensor
that's used by the
neo minutemen organization and that it's
slow to fire and it's clunky so it's a
sort of spiritual musket of course it's
not a musket in any meaningful technical
sense because it's using uh laser energy
even though you're using muscle power to
crank that up to somehow store up energy
in the capacitor to actually fire it
aesthetically the only real nod to the
musket is i suppose the extended rod
that holds the sort of emitter is
reminiscent of a long barrel of a musket
and the wooden butt stock and the big
trigger guard sort of look a bit oldie
worldy i've seen people compare it to
the pennsylvania or kentucky rifle and
yeah there's that war of independence
connection there with the minutemen
organization but those guys are just as
likely if not more likely to be using
french or british muskets or their own
fouling pieces not necessarily a rifle
although some of the concept art had
quite a kentucky rifle buttstock the
final version doesn't so for me it's not
really there as a laser version of the
kentucky rifle
[Music]
some pretty clear uh papasha submachine
gun heritage to this
combat rifle which is clearly meant to
be a
sort of an alternative reality browning
automatic rifle i say clearly i think so
or the initial caliber it's available in
45 which as we can see from the casings
is literally 45 acp that's a bit weird
the magazine is still a full length full
depth rifle type magazine but it's
firing and it's a huge long heavy gun
but it's firing a pistol cartridge that
doesn't make a lot of sense we've got a
bayonet hanging rather
unsecurely from insecurely from the
barrel thing about bayonet mounts is
that they must have a secure robust
mounting system because you are jamming
them into people that mount it's not
even a mount really is it's just the um
the guard of the of the bayonet somehow
is attached to the barrel that bit of
metal is so thin and there's such a
lever there it that thing is going to
bend um and for
what is really quite at least with the
with the upgraded full caliber version
quite a heavy powerful weapon you don't
typically put a bayonet on that anyway
[Applause]
another curious design the so-called
assault rifle it's not super clear to me
in what way this is a an assault rifle i
mean you can upgrade it to be automatic
but it doesn't come automatic by
definition it couldn't be an assault
rifle because an assault rifle must be
automatic capable none of that i don't
think any of the automatic capable guns
in the game come as automatic you have
to find a specific receiver to allow
that which isn't quite how that works
but um we'll overlook that so let's
assume that it's an automatic version
and it's in 5.56 yeah it's a form of an
assault rifle but what is with the
gigantic cooling jacket which is itself
a puzzle because it's clearly based on
the lewis guns cooling jacket which is
an air cooling jacket a radiator
essentially inside an outer sheath the
lighter coloured flanges at the back
there are the inner aluminium radiator
that sits around the barrel
and then it has a
basically a heat shield over that partly
to protect the user but primarily for to
allow this um interesting forced cooling
system where the muzzle gases pull cold
air in through those veins at the back
and over the barrel to cool it very
clever interesting system it's the only
gun that i'm aware of that did that and
it's on this assault rifle this also has
a filling port at the back for water and
a big old bit of plumbing hanging off
the bottom of it that goes somewhere
under the gun and does something so on
the face of it it's actually a water
jacket but that doesn't seem to factor
into how it's actually used in the game
so it's a weird mashup of lewis gun and
then it's got aspects of weirdly the
minimally light machine gun so that
lower receiver slash handguard is
visually based upon
the minimize handguard and the butt stop
looks to be reminiscent of the
collapsing butt stock on the minimi as
well although
you have to kind of squint so kind of a
kind of a cool star wars style visual
mashup of guns from different periods in
in our own history
so this is what's what's i sometimes
known as a gauss gun or gauss rifle as
it is in this case same thing as a coil
gun which is using electromagnetic coils
to accelerate a solid projectile like a
bullet to uh often extremely high
velocities to achieve very high
penetration splash damage on armor that
kind of thing we have those in the real
world that are the size of vehicles the
energy requirements are such that you
cannot produce a shoulder-fired version
like this and there's no real prospect
short of like miniature fusion reactors
which of course we have here of being
able to achieve that so it's very much a
very much a sci-fi thing as are all of
those partly part of the the aesthetic
of this that i enjoy and makes it seem
very alternate cold war are the digits
on the the readout on the back of the
gun which look like sort of vacuum tube
old style readouts which is which is
cool
as well as the the copper wire coils and
the capacitor valve things there's a lot
of visual interest going on here even if
it's not a believable design
[Applause]
one of the real world firearms of course
is the 44 pistol which is pretty good
copy of
this thing the smith wesson model 29
this one has a an excessively long
barrel those of us of a certain age will
think dirty harry now something i've
noticed this time that i've not while
playing the game is they've gone to the
trouble of modeling the
notch in the top of the hammer if you
look at it in first person view which is
actually meant to house this
replaceable firing pin replaceable
because
they can break and it's cheaper to
replace
just that bit than the whole hammer and
that's missing from this model so um
either the gun they had for reference or
the image they had was missing the
firing pin quite possible or they just
didn't notice it but um as as depicted
there's nothing to actually fire the
cartridge i will say i don't think
there's enough recoil modeled in this
with this thing certainly relative to
the other hand guns it's recoiling in a
pretty similar way
i mean clint eastwood used to
almost over exaggerate mime the recoil
of this thing but at least it implied
that it was firing something potent we
don't see anything like that here the
player must have wrists of steel i think
because this is a 44 magnum is an old
cartridge but it's still really quite
powerful
something
new to fallout 4 was this whole kind of
ecosystem um a marketing person might
call it of pipe weapons so
guns built around the idea of
readily available steel pipes
that would be lying around the destroyed
world good idea not the first time we've
seen it but uh
an interesting implementation of it a
lot of the designs are not tremendously
plausible though there's there's been
more attention to the aesthetics than to
how they would actually function if they
were real but it does it appeals in
terms of the ability to change their
appearance and how they function by
bolting different bits on it kind of
makes intuitive sense that you could do
that so here we've got the
308 handgun which is never a good idea
that's a tremendous amount of recoil to
be contained by a handgun least of all
one that's been assembled from hardware
store components so i don't fancy this
much with or without the big jagged
spike sticking to the front of it
although in keeping with the rusty
aesthetic of these guns the site this
this particular site with two screws
coming in from either side to form like
a crude reticle really makes zero sense
there's no point having a scope tube if
there's no glass in it frankly it's not
magnifying it's not achieving anything
you're not even getting a fixed point of
aim that you could calibrate you could
zero the gap between the points of the
misaligned screws is really not going to
help you aim very much at all better
than nothing but not much you'd be far
better off trying to put a single screw
on the front of the barrel and probably
calling it a day there at least giving
you some sort of aiming reference point
bigger issue for this rifle is the feed
setup so we've got this side mounted
magazine then we've got the much bigger
issue that the geometry of that magazine
well doesn't work it's significantly
below the level of the bolt so there's
no way for the bolt to pick up around
and feed it so there's not not this
hasn't been quite
thought through
so this
so the reason we've got this redundant
locking piece screwed to the side of the
of the gun is that this is meant to be
the same basic gun that you are adapting
into different roles i can't remember if
it quite works that way in the game or
not but it's yeah it's the same piece of
wood it's the same metal plates and
stock and even the same bolt even the
same looking thing so you are we're
expected to believe that we are
effectively
turning a bolt action into an automatic
weapon without really changing anything
like as much as we would have to to
accomplish that and vice versa so with
this uh scoped version here that's
firing 50 caliber ammunition okay we are
now locking the the literal bolt vault
handle into the locking wedge
shoulder thing that's hanging off the
side of the gun that's a nod to the fact
that this is a bolt action and would
need to be manually locked shut firing
but there's no way that this thing is
going to take the chamber pressures of
50 browning machine gun
as you know my job title is keeper of
firearms and artillery i am responsible
for the artillery collection here at the
royal armouries so it's quite gratifying
to see a take on a piece of artillery in
a game and especially the admittedly
silly fantasy conceit of a
man portable cannon it's got pneumatic
recoil dampeners in it which is a nice
try i don't think they would be
sufficient to take the the recoil of an
actual cannon the design of the gun
itself isn't really historically correct
it's got the lines of a traditional
cannon yeah the profile is not really
correct for any particular era or
country it has got the british royal
cipher appears to be gr so one of the
georges uh we complete with the crown of
course the actual practicalities of
using this again so the recoil would
still be too much dampened or not and
what's supposed to happen is you hold
that sort of armature in place and as
you can see the gun itself pivots
downward to give access to the muzzle
for reloading big problem there is we're
not putting any gun powder in our gun
powered powered gun so we're just
putting the projectile in there no
propellant which is obviously a problem
because nothing would happen
[Music]
another gun from this game that i'm not
familiar with believe it's dlc thing but
i am familiar with it because although
it's called the radium rifle and
inexplicably fires radioactive
ammunition it's actually a pretty close
copy of this
the volkswagen
it's a very interesting design for a
number of way around number of reasons
none of those involve radioactive
bullets so this thing was
nor was any as far as i know second
world war firearm designed to fire
radioactive bullets the closest we've
ever come is depleted uranium which is
called depleted uranium for a reason it
may not be entirely safe but it is not
intended to insert radiation into its
target so why have they chosen this as
the basis for that rifle your guess is
as good as mine it's probably worth
noting that this does seem to have been
adapted for the purpose so whatever
whatever those various electrical bits
and bobs do to irradiate the ammunition
it does seem that this is a modifier
modification improvisation adaptation
from a real gun so we could be looking
at somehow rather far in the future a
very very rare last ditch wartime gun
that has been adapted for radioactive
purposes i say this not only because it
looks like it's been adapted but because
you can't use the sights they haven't
actually modeled the front sight pose
anyway but you can't even see the front
sight assembly because whatever that is
is attached over the top of the barrel
so you are not actually able to aim
properly with it which would suggest
that this has been modified and the
modification is deemed more important
than the ability to hit anything
[Applause]
so second time in a row for the
semi-famous
shovel ak we covered this in rust last
time yes that is a spade grip on the
back of that kalashnikov so back in 2008
there was a
chat who was inspired to make his own
kalashnikov which was legal for him to
do where he was he not only put the
literal spade grip on the back of the
receiver the receiver itself was forged
by him from the blade of the same
shuffle this is a a riff on essentially
a meme but it's a real gun we've also
got a horrific looking tanto bladed
monster of a
utility knife i suppose you know
tactical knife you might call it that is
inadequately secured to the muzzle of
this thing the real stand out for me
other than all of that is this is a
kalashnikov in a fallout game and like
many
fallout slash gun nerds i was given to
understand that there was no kalashnikov
in the fallout universe and that its
alternative reality equivalent was the
chinese assault rifle so this is quite
the bombshell for the likes of me for
the kalashnikov to now be canon in the
fallout universe
the institute made a point of getting my
hands on one of these because it was new
and interesting it's a slightly more
sci-fi take on a fallout energy weapon
for me it's also perhaps inspired by the
likes of weta workshop who've done some
amazing work with sci-fi weapons of all
kinds the back end is quite reminiscent
of if you've seen the tomorrow war the
ar-15s in that were equipped with hero
arms furniture so this style of blocky
thumb hole butt stop quite similar to
that i'm always amused by super
high-tech weapons that have not only
iron sights when you would expect
something clearly this is an opportunity
to upgrade your weapon in in this case
not only iron sights but super basic
iron sights that look like i made them
with some tin snips really kind of
detracts from the overall sci-fi look of
the of the weapon
do go over and check out the royal
armouries youtube channel as well as the
rest of this one we also got link links
in the description for ways to donate to
the museum if you'd like to do that or
my book on british bullpup firearms
which has been out for a while now and
it's still available via headstamp is
also now available from the rural
armouries shop which is better for
people who are located on this side of
the globe so if you're interested check
that out as well but
otherwise we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you